good afternoon
everyone good afternoon
everyone all
right I was in a bunch of Southern
churches recently were you just got to
you either do it right or you don't do
it you know um welcome I'm David blight
director of Gilder lman center for the
study of slavery resistance and
abolition um this is what we call the
David Brian Davis lecture series which
we founded I don't know at least six
seven years ago now in honor of my
colleague David Brian Davis who is right
here in the front row uh David was the
founder of this
Center some 13 years ago another way of
putting it is the center was founded
around David's
work uh which is still where everyone
goes to understand
especially uh the intellectual history
of the problem of slavery uh in the
world for that matter David was doing a
kind of transnational history of this
before anyone ever used the word
transnational um so so welcome David and
we've done this in many different forms
we've had a single
lecture uh go away at people for three
or four days in a row we've we've had
panels we've had a series of lectures
and so forth sometimes we produce a book
and today we're just going to hopefully
produce a lot of really interesting hot
air on a subject that has I think some
currency uh this is of course the Civil
War sesa Centennial if you haven't
noticed those of us in this field uh
have more than
noticed uh we can't seem to help it um a
year ago now in the spring of
2011 uh some of you may remember uh just
about this time March and April everyone
in the
Press uh from major magazines to
newspapers to radio stations everywhere
had to do some kind of piece on I don't
know the meaning in me memory of the
Civil War at its 150th
anniversary uh at that point as members
of this panel will remember it was often
the first question from the reporter at
some newspaper in North Carolina or
Connecticut was
so was it really about
slavery
or what about that black Confederate
thing uh it's as though there are
some resonant quick stories always that
they're out there for journalists the
press to grab on to um when they need to
and of course our job was always to
deepen that story in whatever two
minutes they would give us um I want to
quickly introduce the panel uh as quick
as I can this is not a group that's easy
to to um introduce quickly I also want
to say we're doing C-SPAN we're going to
try to keep this on
time uh we're also streaming live on the
Yale website I think
um and I'm going to introduce everybody
and then here's what we're going to do
I'm going to I'm going to offer a very
brief definition of legacy just one
attempt at that word just briefly it
occurred to me that since I've asked
everybody to talk about legacies so
before they ask me to Define it I'll
offer a definition and then I've asked
each member of the panel to take two
minutes that's all they get to declare
their favorite or could be unfavorite or
least favorite Legacy of the Civil War
they get two minutes to State it and
defend it and then we're going to go
from there our first guest is tanasi
coats who's immediately to my well two
people to my right
sorry sorry I'd like to be
tanasi you've been reading his blog
tanasi is a senior is a senior head
editor at Atlantic magazine he writes
both for the magazine and a and a now
quite prominent blog he has many fans on
his blog as I have learned in fact I
don't know was at least a few years ago
I started hearing from Friends Tom
thirston my colleague is one of them who
kept saying you got to start reading
this guy he's talking about your books a
lot so I started reading him um he's the
author of A Memoir called the beautiful
struggle about growing up in West
Baltimore that Memoir is among other
things a father and son story a riveting
Father and Son story tanasi father was a
black panther and also a Vietnam
veteran it's a memoir that seems
inspired by uh you can correct this if
you want the era of Hip Hop and uh it
seems to be in some ways a search uh for
a kind of
nonviolent uh masculine identity if I
could put it that way um in the 80s and
90s when uh he was on his way to Howard
University he's a journalist who's
worked for the voice Time Magazine he's
written for the New York Times magazine
Washington Post a lot of other papers
he's also now writing fiction about
which I believe he spoke earlier today
in a student forum and most recently
among the other kinds of blogs he's done
in the Civil War he wrote a piece called
why do so few blacks study the Civil War
which my undergraduate seminar just
recently read and I also quickly add I
had one of the most interesting
conversations by telephone with tanasi
last late last fall I think think um
about the idea of tragedy maybe we we'll
come back to that Andrew delbo I'm going
an alphabetical order on the the end of
the line is one of the preeminent
literary cultural historians of our time
chairs American studies uh and is
Professor of the humanities at
Colombia he was just awarded the
National Humanities medal by President
Obama uh he was once called by Time
Magazine America's best social critic
author of many
books whether you wanted that label or
not
apparently uh among many books I'll just
mention two brand new ones both coming
out this year that's not fair by the way
it's just Andy nobody should publish two
books in one year uh one is called the
Abolitionist
imagination uh which I read in
manuscript it's a it's a long essay a
probing provocative essay about the
reputation of abolitionists with four
people responding and very soon to be
reviewed by David Brian Davis and New
York Review of Books you two can deal
with that later uh and then the book
called College uh what it was what it
was is and should be which uh Andy was
interviewed about on Connecticut public
radio yesterday if any of you happen to
hear it probably most prominently he's
known for his great biography of Herman
Melville um it's on my short list of
biographies to model if you're trying to
do biography about a writer which I am
and it's a it's a great book he also
wrote the book called The Death of Satan
um which is a book about American
culture in the Civil War era edited the
portable Lincoln etc etc and he commonly
writes for the New York Review of Books
Gary Gallagher uh in the middle of our
our
lineup uh is the professor of the of the
American Civil War at the University of
Virginia he taught for years at Penn
State before going to
UVA uh Gary grew up in Colorado in
California he went to graduate school at
Texas and I don't know what it is but it
maybe the Texas hook that makes the Neo
Confederates always think that he ought
to be one of them until they find out
he's not um but any rate um um for years
he edited a series with University of
North Carolina press which has produced
some of the best books we have about the
Civil War era um several of which he
wrote himself he's the author are editor
of 30 books I'll just mention a few the
Confederate War uh the book called
causes one lost and forgotten how
Hollywood and popular art shaped what we
know about the Civil War he's the
Hollywood expert on this Lee and his
Generals in war and
memory a particular favorite of mine if
you work on memory and just recently the
book called The Union War which my
graduate uh seminar read and took apart
as graduate seminars always do yesterday
afternoon so who knows what questions
may come from them Gary watch out uh
Gary I will also say he's one of the
most sought-after speakers on this
subject in the United States and his
lectures are online or in many different
places electronically uh if you want to
look for them Stephanie McCurry uh next
to and between Andy and Gary uh taught
for some years at San Diego State and at
Northwestern and has been at theity to
Pennsylvania now was professor of
history for 8 nine maybe 10 years by now
she was born in Belfast uh her family
immigrated to Canada she went to high
school in
Canada um and then came to the US to
graduate school she did her PhD at Sunni
Bingington uh she's been one of the most
imaginative historians we have on
matters of gender race class among other
things about southern history and about
Amer American history um she uh her
first book called masters of small
worlds about yman households was a
multiple prizewinning book and still
rests on almost
everybody's reading list and graduate
reading Stephanie only rights books that
end up on graduate reading lists her
newest book called Confederate Reckoning
power in politics in the Civil War South
just won the Frederick Douglas book
prize which our Center
sponsors um another prizewinning book
and uh Stephie and I have done many
things together in this business most
recently a conference in Israel last
summer which we managed to scheme and
get ourselves invited to which was uh in
in Jerusalem a conference uh comparing
the American Civil War with other civil
wars that was an interesting comparative
moment and finally John wit from the
Yale law school John's Yale College ba
Yale law school Yale PhD in history but
he's actually from Philadelphia and a
Phillies fan so true you know he's the
Alan Duffy class of 1960 professor of
law at Yale they say he teaches torts
and a lot of other things which is
probably true but he's really a
constitutional historian and a great one
several books uh Patriots and
cosmopolitans hidden histories of
American law another entitled The
Accidental Republic crippled working men
destitute widows in the remaking of
American law and now forthcoming soon
yeah very soon Lincoln's code the laws
of war in American
history uh this is a panel I put
together to try to get obviously
different perspectives on this huge
problem of what is a civil war Legacy so
uh I'm going to ask um Andy to go first
Andy yeah two minutes your favorite
Civil War Legacy okay thank you very
much delighted to be here I'm going to
try to say two things in two minutes uh
David gave us a little bit of a heads up
we had a chance to think about this what
popped into my head when he asked me um
was a memory I hadn't thought of in a
while when I was about 10 years old um
grew up in a suburb of New York from a
uh more or less liberal Democratic
family and I had a friend around the
corner who was in a pretty strongly
Republican family and we began to become
aware that something that we now call
the Civil Rights move
was underway and we found ourselves in a
conversation about it and he said to me
at one point the trouble with black
people and in those days of course the
term was Negroes is that they're not
grateful for having been freed from
slavery and uh even to my 10-year-old
ears at that time there was something
off about that statement uh and so the
first thing I would say just to keep it
very succinct is I think one of the
legacies we deal with is that that
sentiment uh is still
around that is what uh who Bears what
responsibility for what happened in
those years what does it mean to be a
full-fledged member of our culture of
our society uh those questions still uh
are obviously unresolved and I'm sure
we'll be talking about that as the
afternoon goes on and unfortunately
there still a lot of people in this
country who would agree with that
10-year-old
sentiment the second thing uh I wanted
to say because I'm an unabashed
presentist as those of you know a little
my work will know I can't help but think
about the past in terms of the present
and I think we're in a in an era where
uh the current president of the United
States and a number of other people are
rather desperately trying to find some
middle ground on which we can proceed
forward into a collective future so I
find myself when I look back at the era
of the Civil War trying to
imagine what it would have been like to
be a person looking for the middle
ground in a situation that retro
respectively it's very clear to us there
was no middle
ground
but though I'm not really a Bonafide
historian exactly I I I think one of the
cardinal principles of thinking about
the past is that one wants to remember
that the people one writes about in the
past did not know the future they were
living ignorant of the future and one of
the things I've tried to stress in in my
recent work is that some decent people
who uh were appalled by slavery uh but
couldn't see a way out of the impass
were trying to find a middle ground and
in fact that's a fair I think
description of what Lincoln was trying
to do for a certain period in his career
uh and many others so
um I find myself thinking about that a
lot so that for me is a sort of personal
intellectual Legacy of of the period and
um I'll stop there thanks thank you um
my graduate seminar yesterday afternoon
may have spent half the period I think
discussing what was good presentism and
what was bad presentism came out of your
book Gary they loved it but it was you
know anyway
uh maybe Andy and I can get into a
discussion I hope so I hope so uh
Stephanie want me to go sure okay so I
want to be a little bit contrary and uh
say that um I think there's a
distinction for me as a historian of the
civil war between the historical Legacy
how I think about the you know the most
important historical Legacy and what I
might think of as the most important
living Legacy memory is history but the
memory of the Civil War is not the
history of the Civil War it's the
history of reconstruction of the Jim
Crow south of the Civil Rights era of
resistance to it the lost cause all of
those things but the history of the war
has to do with events and their meaning
in that time and place and it requires
us as historians to go back to the
documents to the historical record and
see what those events what caused those
events uh in time and place and consult
the record of 1860 to 65 and for me the
questions that that brings up that still
require urgent answer are um you know
what kind of uh a country the
Confederacy wanted to build what was
secession for these versions of the
questions of the causes of the Civil War
and so the history of the war is to use
contemporary EV evidence from the period
to talk about the causes the Dynamics
the consequences and so to me the
historical Legacy and the living Legacy
seem at odds the Civil War was you know
in many ways the simplest way to
understand it I think is it to me at Le
least it was a profound crisis of
legitimacy in American democracy um you
know a war that tried to resolve by
military means a political uh to settle
um something that could not be settled
legislatively or electorally about the
legitimacy of human bondage and about
the power of the government to restrain
it in a Democratic Society that was the
heart of the fight so and the way that
was settled was definitive the
Confederacy was beaten into total and
unconditional surrender
so to me the most important historical
Legacy of the war has to do with the
profound and Lasting significance of
Confederate defeat and it's really easy
to forget that in all the disappointment
of the post-war period um the violence
the disappointment the violence and
betrayal of African-American hopes in
the post-war period you can lose sight
of what was so profound about what was
accomplished after their failure in
proos slavery nationalism after they
were beaten slavery could never be
reinstated or rehabilitated as an
institution in American life and the
hubris of the planner class was
confirmed in the total in their total
and in the total and uncompensated
emancipation of 4 million uh
African-American men women and children
in other words the most important
historical Legacy to me is the simple
fact that because they were defeated
slavery was gone and it would never come
back but that doesn't answer the
question of the living Legacy and there
to me um maybe not surprisingly since I
write about the Confederacy is the most
important living Legacy to me shocking
and bewildering at the same time is the
Never Dying power and appeal of the
Confederate story continually taken up
revised and retold in every post-war
generation why this is escapes me I have
ideas they're just as U valid as the
hundred in this room um I will say
slaveholders had always been the organic
Beating Heart of American conservatism
uh and that was true in the period
between the founding and the Civil War
and I'm a person who thinks it's just as
important to think about the power of
conservatism in American life as the
power of radicalism and Progressive
forces so in that sense it maybe
shouldn't surprise us that Confederates
quick sodic Quest became the very
template for every other conservative
subsequent conservative protest but how
Confederates a people openly convicted
in public opinion of treason and
thoroughly defeated retained the
cultural power and the speech rights to
do what they
did uh remains for me one of the most
important historical questions of the
postwar period I mean David's written a
lot about this but it's still kind of
bewildering to me how they managed to do
it so many post-war societies obviously
strug struggle with the problem of
memory um but usually like in Franco
Spain the victors dictate the terms
right they gag the opposition um the and
the defeated people struggle to keep
alive a buried censored and publicly
disgraced version of their Civil War um
in the United States there were no
treason trials there were no systematic
attempts at political repression there
was no suspension of of speech rights so
where else Ides of the United States did
the defeated retain such power not just
to keep alive their version of the war
but to commercially pedal it um and to
do that from the moment the war ended if
not before and to find a ready and even
expanding audience for that what they
thought of as heroic script the
Confederate epic even up to 150 years
after the ancestral uh that uh ancestral
class of people had been forced into
surrender so that question about the
contrast between democracy and fascism
in its treatment of an a defeated enemy
looms really large but not very clearly
in my mind when I think about the living
Legacy of the Civil War which is the
troubling question of why treason and
defeat seem to make a better
story I think we got to come back to
that
one Gary are we just coming down the
line sure right down the road I'm going
to keep this very short because I think
we're going to have a lot of fun this
afternoon I'm going to mention two
legacies very quickly and one is you're
allowed to you're allowed they're going
to be very short David one is there the
very large number of people who are
drawn to the Civil War I suspect some
people in this room U may fall into that
category I do I grew up in I'm from Los
Angeles I live there and in Southern
Colorado the Civil War has nothing to do
with Los Angeles and Southern Colorado
it captivated me as a young person and
I've been in a wut now for more years
well you can guess how many years just
with a glance a very long time and it's
such a stupendously expansive topic that
there is endless opportunity to go in
different directions it never becomes
stale it never becomes boring the sheer
size of it the importance of the issues
that were at stake they don't get more
important the questions are not more
important at any point in American
history than the questions there would
issue during the Civil War and the cast
of characters of course is very
difficult uh to beat a president in the
United States who wrote his own speeches
uh and that didn't last two hours think
about that for a minute so there's a lot
going on that simply engages people and
always has but I think the most obvious
long-term Legacy of the Civil War it's
so stunningly obvious that we don't
think of it very often even though as a
guild we historians want to place
everything into World context what does
it mean within a world context quit
Naval gazing as historians of the United
States the obvious most important
outcome of the American Civil War is
that the American Republic maintained
its status as a single increasingly
powerful Republic and went forward in a
way that economically militarily and
culturally it wielded an in an enormous
amount of influence which would not have
been possible had the Confederacy
succeeded had the Confederacy succeeded
you would have had at least two
republics in North America and we all
love Canada but you would have had two
republics in North America uh that were
buying for a greater part on the world
stage but those two together could not
possibly have wielded the influence that
the United States wielded and it did
that and has wielded and continues to
wield for good or for ill but it does
because the United States triumphed
during the Civil War and the Confederacy
did not I think that's the greatest
Legacy so Union victory was important I
I do believe it was I do believe it was
yes and some people don't no I no and
sometimes they send you emails I got one
last
fall wishing that I would develop a case
of virulent pancreatic cancer because
I'm mean to the
Confederacy virulent not just regular
pancreatic cancer the virulent kind
they're right but not the the
prescription's terrible but they're
right I'm I'm finished okay okay good
all right
tanasi um I I I the best way for me to
illustrate this I don't have a
particularly objective answer I have an
entirely subjective answer and I'll just
get this none of us are subjectives
don't okay all
right um I think modern Black America is
the most important Legacy of the Civil I
shouldn't say it's my favorite Legacy of
the Civil War and frankly uh it's
virtually impossible for me to think
about my very existence uh without the
Civil War I grew up in a household that
was suffused with a political struggle
and particularly the political struggle
of African-Americans and though I didn't
know it at the time it's quite clear
that that political struggle dated back
uh to the Civil War um my father as
David mentioned was a black panther uh
in uh Baltimore the most probably most
radical wing of the soil right sort of
black power struggle my parents met
there um had they not met there I would
not be sitting on this panel today
um so it's very easy for me to say that
uh in in the most subjective way but I
think even more importantly than that
when you think about this in a in a sort
of
um in a sort of bigger way when you
think about African-Americans the entire
people
um what I didn't understand until I
started taking this path back into
history is that there very much was
another option on the table and that is
black people not being here at all uh
black people being recolonized leaving
for Africa leaving for the Caribbean
maybe leaving for some other part of a
yet determined United States uh what
have you the fact that not just the
slaves were free but that the slaves
remained here I think just had
incredible consequences uh for the
country I mean we can talk about the
obvious good when we think about the
freedom struggles uh of of various
different groups when we think about uh
women when we think about the current
marriage equality struggles all this
stuff dates back to the Civil Rights
Movement which itself dates back uh to
the Civil War uh one of the most
stunning things that I came across in my
very recent study uh was just when you
start studying the women's rights
movement and you see how many of of
those folks started out as
emancipationist I'm sorry as
abolitionists excuse me uh when you hear
Sarah grimy say something like by
looking into the rights of slaves I gain
deeper insight into my own rights as a
woman that's a mangled quote but that's
basically the essence of of what she
said it's impossible for me to picture
America as it is today uh without
picturing African-Americans as a
political force without picturing uh
African-Americans as a cultural Force
where would we be without Jazz what is
America uh without Jazz without its
popular music um when you think about
these questions that uh our president is
uh facing right now uh why does a
majority of Republican voters in
Mississippi regard him as a Muslim I
think all of that goes back to the Civil
War and the difficulty of accepting
African-Americans as full Americans uh
as uh full citizens as full participants
in our lecture and I think that that
causes a great degree of problems where
it's not even obvious uh when you talk
about uh um putting in place policy uh
that you know presumably is for all of
America uh but when you see
African-Americans at the Forefront of it
uh it sort of distorts it in a way that
I don't necessarily think uh it always
would so uh my answer not to be flip I
hope I'm not being fli is uh me I'm most
important see it all boils down to me
it's all about me at the end of the day
uh but no it do seriousness I think it's
the presence of African-Americans in the
United
States okay well uh John
Whit uh I should uh I should start by um
observing that uh this is the David
Brian Davis lecture and uh David Davis
was one of the great Inspirations for me
I mean it was as a junior in college
just right down the way that I started
thinking about some of these things in a
seminar that that he taught and so I'm
enormously great to be here today so
thank you uh two two candidates were
allowed to so uh one uh and this draws
on on um we just um we've just been
talking about uh the legal and
constitutional History of the United
States since the Civil War uh is
organized in large part around the
Reconstruction amendments and an ongoing
battle to decide what the the Amendments
that follow the Civil War mean uh many
of the contests that uh uh our
candidates for the legacies find one of
their principal forums in the courts and
in social movements that are claiming to
articulate the true meaning uh with many
different views about what that true
meaning might be of the Reconstruction
amendments the 13th Amendment abolishing
slavery abolishing involuntary servitude
and giving Congress the authority to
enforce it the 14th Amendment uh giving
citizens privileges and immunities
guaranteeing all persons due process of
the laws and equal protection of the
laws and giving the congress power to
enforce it and the 15th Amendment
Banning discrimination uh in in voting
um these are the three transformative
Constitutional Amendments of of our
legal and constitutional history and
much of what's gone on since then in the
law and in constitutional law in the
Supreme Court there are a series of
arguments about about those uh about
those um amendments this is played out
in areas like affirmative action race
discrimination so Brown versus Board of
Education and its project
uh are the product of this um but it
goes way beyond that I mean the the
number of different features of American
law that are shaped and could not be UND
cannot be understood otherwise except
through these amendments it knows no
bounds gun rights your handgun rights
which you now have you didn't a couple
years ago but now you do uh are run
through the 14th Amendment I mean
there's no Connecticut handgun Second
Amendment right absent the 14th
Amendment which has been understood to
incorporate as against states rights
that were only before the Civil War uh
held by by by individuals as against the
federal government uh most criminal
procedure law is the result of the 14th
Amendment uh uh the list goes on and on
so this is a huge Legacy of the Civil
War uh it's one that's fought out uh all
the time uh just uh seven years ago nine
years ago Justice o'conor former Justice
o Conor said that she hoped that maybe
in about 25 years questions of
affirmative action in higher education
uh uh admission policies might be able
to be race blind as a matter of
constitutional mandate and I think when
she said that what she meant was that
maybe in in 25 years from then uh the
battle over the Civil War would at last
be over uh it turns out the Supreme
Court's probably going to end that next
year um uh they just granted SAR on a
Case hey we're worried enough about
Healthcare don't make us it's so so the
SEC second Legacy uh quickly and this
draws on an observation Gary made is the
beginning I think of sustained moral and
legal and and Military deliberations on
what it means to be a great power uh uh
we see in the Lincoln Administration uh
for the first time in American history
that I'm aware of a sustained thinking
and deliberation and debate about what
it means to exercise the huge power that
comes with an industrialized military
force and this ranges from Lincoln's
extraordinary just war deliberations in
the fall of summer and fall of 1862 to
the elaboration of a code of of Rules of
Engagement that purport to be
international law which are still with
us today in in the international law
that we have from the hay conventions
and the Geneva conventions and last in
the construction of a a series of
military commissions uh which try
thousands and thousands of people and
are right now being argued about in
federal courts in Washington DC uh you
know virtually every week and in the
coming weeks the federal district court
for the federal court of appeals for the
District of Columbia will decide a case
in which the parties are right now
arguing about the legacy of the Civil
War uh and the question about and their
question their central question is
whether or not the expansions that
Lincoln and his administration made in
the military authority to U take over
territory that had once been exclusively
the territory of the Civil courts ought
to be an authority for military
commissions uh for the 21st century so
the the legacy of the Civil War and
these questions about the United as a
military power moral questions legal
questions and Military strategy and
tactics questions is really palpable uh
and is an important part of the
conversation I
think wow you know I don't need to
define a legacy at all I think we just
did uh since I forgot to so anyway um uh
I'm going to I'm going to go in the
order that these were raised and get us
all to to to weigh in on this
Andy your point about
how does one understand how Americans
find compromise find a middle ground you
reminded me
immediately one of the things Robert pen
Warren wrote about 50 years ago right
now in his little book Legacy of the
Civil War was that he he believed the
Civil War gave us pragmatism now
pragmatism maybe a little older than the
Civil War but his whole point was that
this this era of such terrible bloody
extremes horri horrifying extremes
brought about in America and Louis Manan
has written about this many people have
written about this brought about in the
next generation at least or even that
generation a philosophical Outlook or
temperament we've come to call
pragmatism Allah William James and
others is that gone can that kind of
thing truly be defeated I mean we we
think we
we're living on you know the our current
word is polarization that's a nice word
isn't it for political deadlock
political hatred political Civil War but
is pragmatism dying
now I mean in the political Arena I mean
it may not be among you know reflective
College professors
but well I mean I don't want to take
us away from our topic but it's my hope
that we're sort of lumbering uh
unwittingly unconsciously half blindly
into into some kind of uh middle middle
ground that um we'll find whether we're
exactly looking for it or not but that's
probably an expression of completely
groundless Faith um look you raised so
many questions you
know for me one of the features of the
Civil War is that um we are mesmerized
by it because we can we can't imagine
death and Terror and destruction on such
a scale at least not on the on the
Homeland territory now in fact it turns
out to have been a preview pretty good
preview of the 20th century in some of
the ways that have been mentioned the
invention of total Total
War uh an ideology based on on racial
hierarchy versus an ideology at least in
theory based on individual dignity we
saw that war being fought fought out
again in the 20th century uh and in some
ways one could conceivably make the
argument that all these
catastrophes were as a result of the
failure of of a pragmatic Spirit of
compromise when we look at the you know
the vimar Republic collapsed and we all
know what happened after that
so you know I think one thing one can
gain from a study of the Civil War is a
sense of what the stakes can be I mean
we in a moment now where the stakes seem
very high to a lot of people right we're
waiting to see whether the Supreme Court
is going to strike down what I think is
a kind of middleway compromise on
healthc care right on the one hand
there's a large faction in our country
that believes A Single Payer system uh
uh run by the government is the way to
go and then on the other side there's a
faction that believes the private Market
is the way to go and what we have is an
effort to find some middle ground and it
looks like it's going to come apart now
the cost of that in my view will be
quite high but it won't be uh on a on a
scale of the of the of the cost of the
Civil War so studying a a world
historical event as a number of people
at this table have accurately described
it and seeing um from a from one
perspective what is the cost when the
when the political process doesn't work
uh is a is a sort of sobering reminder
to us of how suddenly catastrophy he can
sort of sneak up on us now that let me
just quickly
say that that is not to deny all the
positive statements that have been made
about the legacies of the Civil War I
mean without it there wouldn't be the
United States there wouldn't be the
United States with free black PE people
in it as a very significant part of the
culture it wouldn't be all the other
things that we take for granted so in
retrospect it doesn't look like a
catastrophe it looks like a Great Leap
Forward but for those in the middle of
it it didn't feel so so good it was it
would would be my my
suspicion um Gary on this issue in your
book Union War you make a forceful case
um for the fact that millions of
Northerners fought this war to save the
union the United
States uh in fact I've never read a book
on the Civil War where the term United
States was used as much quite I know you
well it's quite explicit on your
part are you in any way as a thoughtful
historian that has to live in the
present concerned that there's a death
of pragmatism that there the belief in
Union the belief in this this coh
ultimate aim of a cohesive Republic is
endangered based on you know your study
of what union meant in the 19th century
do we do we have a language even of
Union anymore I'm not sure we do have
that language anymore and another
another thing we don't have and this
this plays off what um you were saying I
don't think we have much of a sense of
the Civil War or anything else in our
history and I think an indication of
that is the sort of hysterical treatment
of everything that happens now it's the
worst there's never been anything like
this we've never been as divided as we
are now there's never been a problem
with immigration like there is now the
only way you can believe that is if your
historical memory goes back to last
Thursday because if goes back very far
at all you know very well that we've
been through far more traumatic things
than we're going through now and I think
it would be very helpful for us to have
that historical context in mind I think
it would equip us better to deal with
what we have in front of us now instead
of having this Armageddon likee view of
what's going on I think that the that
the loyal white population the United
the free states were
98.8% white according to the 1860 census
that's something we we need to remind
ourselves of when we think about the
past the past is a different country in
many ways and demographically it
certainly was when you're talking about
the loyal citizenry they're almost all
white and most of them alas did not care
much about black people most of them
embraced emancipation as a tool to
preserve the union I believe I think the
evidence is very strong on that but they
had a collective sense of what the union
meant and I'm I don't think that we have
perhaps that strong a sense now and I
don't think I don't think we should all
have a
poana notion of what the United States
is and stands for but I think that it
helps to have some common sense of what
the project is about and I'm not sure we
have that we don't have when we listen
to candidates sometimes well Rick santor
declared this election the most
important since 1860 in in Gettysburg it
was in Gettysburg yes there was a battle
there so sure one thing that just step
one thing that just occurred to me
listening to this and I don't know I
mean there people again here with much
more historical knowledge than me but
being someone who does quite a bit of
political analysis um I agree with the
notion of uh a really brief historical
memory I think it was new gang Rich who
said that um about 18 which lends at
this kind of intellectual veneer um that
everything he says somehow in N says it
it really means something but I I wonder
if um part of this is not the price of
seeding the historical memory to a
certain section of the country m so uh
one of the things I noticed uh when
again I started making my journey back
into the Civil War is outside of people
who are actual historians or writers the
Civil War belongs the public memory to a
certain group of people um and when you
do that the rest of the country says
okay that's for them that that's not for
us and so I wonder about the
implications of that which is who uh
which who does it belong to who does it
belong to oh it PR pretty much belongs
to white Southerners with confederate uh
sensibilities and that's been my
experience um I don't think that's in
fact true but um whenever you visit the
battle Parks uh that's really the
impression that you get that it's really
not for you it's for uh another group of
people and at first I thought that was
just me as an African-American but the
more I think about it I think it's
actually uh quite bigger than that so I
wonder if you decide that the historical
memory isn't for you um how how are you
able to call upon it when you think
about your current
politics step well I also I read
something you wrote about this that
really struck me uh resonated with me
and it has to do with the problem I've
always had feeling invested in this idea
of compromise in 1860 at all it's
extremely difficult to teach I mean
you're supposed to think compromise is
the desirable outcome but how are you
supposed to think that in 1860 yeah who
are you rooting for in 1860 when when
when the people you know we talk we you
talked about the middle ground the
middle ground was upper South unionists
who would have sold people into slavery
into the indefinite future just like the
people who joined the Confederacy it's
hard to back them they're the ones who
are bargaining with Seward over uh you
know shutting down the show so that uh
there is no threat to slavery
everything's going to you know he's
going to give away the store Lincoln
won't let him and so compromise is
impossible and you have to feel that how
could you morally back compromise in
that particular context and you wrote
about this a little bit when you were
talking about how an African-American
Narrative of the Civil War just kind of
ruptures the story and this is one of
the main ways it ruptures the story but
I can't really feel very comfortable
with that story myself they're not my
guys I don't really want them to win
compromise is not the solution in this
case any compromise in a there's no way
that anybody understood a scenario in
1860 or 61 by which slavery would have
been eradicated in four years
uncompensated and total except the
scenario that we had war and state
sponsored emancipation and they only
ever do it and doesn't doesn't matter
what country it is almost all these
emancipations come when they want
soldiers for the Army so it's a military
emancipation policy it's a military
emancipation policy in the union and
it's a military emancipation well a
military enlistment policy in the
Confederacy so I just I find the whole
idea of the middle ground and of
political compromise in 1860 just really
deeply troubling and it's very hard to
write a narrative around that without
disturbing that assumption and once you
disturb it it's hard even to teach um
that per for that reason do you think
that's generational at all I mean just
think back to the just to give it a
label the David Donald generation great
civil war
historian started writing in the 40s U
and it was part of that generation that
that was wishing there had been more of
a compromised culture was only the
politicians hadn't been so bumbling yeah
I mean David really he was trained by
James Randall who was one of the
needless War School leaders blendering
generation blundering generation yeah
but I mean is our gener Our Generation
Um that's always a troubling phrase to
use wrong anybody isn't it but uh let's
just say people of our ilk um you know
that we've been have we grown up uh
appreciating conflict that is
understanding historical change as
conflict not certainly do yeah yes on my
part yeah okay okay Andy well no just
you know
one can't disagree I mean this is the I
find myself in a right difficult Paradox
when I when we get into this topic but I
guess that's the place that I choose to
be uh we make compromises all the time
right we're compromising with all kinds
of uncontable behavior because of the
clothes we wear because we walk down the
street as free people in a country where
millions of people are
incarcerated uh in many cases Way Beyond
what I think on any rational moral
analysis would lead us to conclude they
ought to be uh and there are people in
this country who speak with just the
same passion that uh Stephanie just
spoke with about other issues on which
they feel that any kind of compromise is
to give away the moral ground completely
now we may not agree with them certain
issues like abortion for instance I
don't mean to presume what people think
about that in this room but we will have
to recognize that and they will use John
Brown as their model absolutely so we
have to recognize that there are people
in this country and there are fellow
citizens and they have the same Free
Speech rights that we have who believe
that uh there are issues right now that
we are blind to and that we're selling
our souls by not acting against they may
not they may be international issues
rather than National ones but you know
we need I think we need to take that
view seriously and it might help us to
feel a little bit more how complicated
it was to be uh an American uh in in
maybe not in eight Night by 1860 but in
the the decade that led up to the
situation of 1860 but even by 1860 I
mean there are hard truths we need to
come to terms with with the Civil
Warrior and one of them is nobody's
talking about a compromise relating to
the institution of slavery itself the
the place they're trying to compromise
is on the extension of slavery that's
where the argument is no one's arguing
no one beyond what would have been
considered the Abolitionist Fringe is
arguing for emancipation in 1860 what
the Civil War is a PL perfect example of
is how Wars rage out of control and
bring consequences no one could have
anticipated the end of slavery in four
years no one could have anticipated that
absolutely no one and the only reason it
happens is because three million men
take up arms and that makes many things
possible I mean it seems to me we've
stumbled on with David gentle guidance
another another Legacy which down which
is which is that I can't remember the
moment which is that that the Civil War
experience frames both a powerful
impulse towards moral modesty about our
passions and about our views of
objectives and political ends that's the
lesson of uh of of Robert Penn Warren's
pragmatism it's Edmund Wilson's lesson
from the war it's uh Lewis Manan I was
just teaching this morning Oliver wend
Holmes Jr who you know injured three
times during the war shot in the chest
shot in the neck balls Bluff and tum and
Chancellorsville uh and and comes out of
that experience and went into the war is
one of the maybe relatively few
abolitionist uh officers and comes out
of the war convinced that his moral
passions and the moral passions of his
colleagues were were foolish mistakes uh
so so it it frames our our moral modesty
the passion itself was the problem
that's right but it also frames the
passionate social projects that people
have engaged in ever since so the the
Civil Rights Movement borrows on the
language of the abolitionists the the
women's rights movement of the 19th
century borrows powerfully and this is
what time n she said uh so we have all
of these social movements that organize
themselves around the models of
abolition as the one great you know
relatively uh uh relatively pure uh uh
example of of extraordinary social
reform in our country but also we called
on to be modest at the same time by the
same events can sure I want to make a
quick argument uh just a little bit con
to Andy uh arguing for why slavery is
just a little different uh if you look
at a state like South Carolina or
Mississippi uh where you're talking
about the majority of the people who
live they are enslaved
um I think slavery is a I guess I'm just
going going to goe I think it's a
particular kind of violence uh when you
talk about the selling of people the
selling of people's children the
division of um of families um I think
that's a little different than Peta and
I guess I'm being presence presentist
right right now but whenever we talk
about pragmatism in inevitably we're
talking about a compromise between two
sides that have power but I don't think
we should have sight of the fact that
there are a great number of people who
have absolutely no power and also I
think be belong in that debate look it
it's an irrefutable point and what the
the the tricky place I find myself when
when I talk on this topic and a slightly
fascinating to me that we've come so
quickly to to this topic nothing I
nothing I'm saying should be
misunderstood I think at least by me or
as any kind of Defense of or sympathy
for uh slave holding or any kind of uh
reduction in our sense of the
heinousness of the crime of slavery but
my but and it's
very difficult to go here but you know
I've once heard someone speak about
comparative
calamy we slavery was slavery and we
have one of the great historians of the
institution of slavery the great
historian of the institution of slavery
sitting right here at the front row
which makes me even more nervous us uh
slavery is clearly one of the great
crimes in the history of
humanity but there have been other great
crimes the gulag the
Holocaust we didn't intervene in time to
stop the Holocaust we what we know what
we know about Stalin retrospectively
what we know about Mau retrospectively
we didn't intervene and I think one of
the answers to David's questions about
why the David Donald generation was
looking for compromise in the middle
ground that was the policy of the 1940s
1950s it was a containment policy we
chose maybe because we didn't have the
power we chose not to intervene in
Horrors you know not a higher scale
lower scale but Horrors that were being
perpetrated against millions of people
we chose not to intervene because we
believe that actually by the through
containment they would eventually be
eradicated and that's what Lincoln
believed in the in the 1850s containment
would eventually lead to the end of
slavery now that's not how it worked out
so it turns out we could say he was
wrong well he he was wrong sort of but
he was right sort of because the
containment policy drove the country to
Civil War and that unleashed the power
that brought slavery to an end I'm just
a little uneasy about saying in in
retrospect it was clear that military
action was the only option and that all
the times we refrained from it ever
since have been
okay and the fact that American slavery
was indeed in the end bludgeoned out of
existence by great violence of course
has so much to do with all of these
legacies let me move though to a
combination of Stephanie and Gary's
ideas the story this beguiling powerful
irresistible story that caught you as a
kid caught me as a kid and Stephanie the
idea why doesn't the Confederacy just go
away I mean it only it's only four years
you know it had had a nice flag what you
know just just go away you know what is
it what is it that makes the Civil War
Story the narratives that we draw from
it so powerful enduring troubling and
why is defeat more
interesting well I think you and I
learned something I know you raised that
but didn't want to have to answer it but
now you do well you I think you and I
learned something about this when we
were in Jerusalem last summer uh about
what it is like even if you think you
you don't have a Sentimental or romantic
approach to the Civil War by being an
American historian of the Civil War you
can be sure that you do and we were told
that repeatedly in the room in Jerusalem
we didn't we thought we were the
outliers in this we against that romance
how dare they we don't love the story in
the way you mean but it turns out that
you know to historians of other civil
wars we look crazily in love with our
civil war even as we're documenting its
Horrors its costs its limitations and
you know to historians of African Civil
Wars the Spanish Civil War the Civil War
in Yugoslavia Ireland remember we have
the paper in Ireland they look at us and
I mean who else not simply commemorates
but celebrates their Civil War who who
and in fact reenacts it who puts Robert
El Le on five postage stamps no well
since he died yes five United States
postage stamps I I there's no other
loser in a Civil War who ended up on
five post even one
even one so I and but I do think that we
have to be really careful which is you
know there's so many Eerie Echoes of the
Civil War in political quarrels in our
own time you know Rick Perry threatening
secession uh various kinds of
nullification threats sometimes you feel
like you're hearing you're just hearing
these Echoes these strange Echoes of the
old debates Norman maer wanted New York
City to secede so
let's so did the mayor of New York
so did the Norwegian immigrants in Upper
Peninsula of Michigan too but but you
know the qu the uh I think the I think
that what I think on the one hand I'm
I'm struck by these and troubled by
these Eerie residences and on the other
hand sometimes they seem like um thin
Reflections and I think part of it is
that this romantic story um the
Confederate appeal is the story of
princip
a principled struggle against tyranny MH
especially the tyranny of the federal
government centralized that can be that
was Jefferson Davis's repre of the real
struggle edman Wilson fell in love with
it it's been available since the
1870s uh it fits many different types
of causes and I think you get thinner
and thinner and thinner versions of it
all the time they're still troubling but
they seem to me very watered down
versions of what was being qu world over
in 1860 and I want to try to remind
myself to remember both things that you
can't take it for granted you have to
fight back against it when you see it
deployed again um because the the
Confederate story feels a little bit
like some vampire story you know
Scholars keep driving a stake through
its heart and saying No this is really
about slavery this is really about SL
and it doesn't matter it just keeps
coming back up as not about slaver
listen to what you just said Scholars
keep driving a stake through the
heart Scholars who listens to Scholars
almost nobody does I mean and I don't
think Jefferson Davis is the key I think
that the that the Lost Cause School of
interpretation took a brilliant turn
very quickly and that was disassociate
this struggle from the institution of
slavery they weren't idiots they knew
that they were out of step with the West
the rest of the western world so let's
play Down slavery let's talk about high
constitutional issues about whether the
central government is powerful or the
state but but that's not the key thing
the key thing is they picked the best
person to focus on and that's re Le you
can talk about him without talking about
slavery you can talk about Chancellor's
bille a victory against the odds you
don't cast it I think so much as the
states against the federal power as
against the underdog waging a gallant
fight over constitutional issues and it
doesn't have anything to do with slavery
especially if you pretend Robert elely
didn't like slavery anyway I mean
they're brilliant about that absolutely
brilliant they don't fool the generation
that wore blue uniforms they never lost
sight of what the war was about but once
that generation was fading it became
more and more and more easy to do that
and when the two most important films in
our history in terms of their social
impact both give a straight Lost Cause
take on things Birth of a Nation and
Gone With the Wind no other film even
close to those in their impact that's a
powerful Gone With the Wind has affected
more people's understanding of the Civil
War more than everything all of us have
done you know multiplied by you pick the
number uh and put together it's true and
Ted Turner loves it but our books are
still for sale out here afterward just
in case your cynicism has not risen too
high anyway but and not to mention that
by 1900 there were 9 million black
people and and not only four and a half
million black people growing and growing
and growing in I mean race is at the
heart of how this story played out to
say the least but B just a quick deal I
mean you know it's good to be realistic
about how much Scholars can change
things but um you know I and I I don't
know much about or know nothing about
grade school and high school textbooks
but I I wonder how many uh students of
American History are asked to read
Alexander Stevens's Cornerstone speech I
mean that would be a pretty effective
antidote to the argument that the Civil
War was not about slavery there it is
laid right out Jefferson was wrong
Jefferson was wrong we in our audience
actually has written so I mean in other
words I think Scholars by by bringing to
light the documents of our past that are
Frank and open about the racial ideology
of the of the Confederacy can make a
contribution and I hope people read
those and confront the what they mean
I've always imagined that the reason
that that Scholars seem drowned out I
never got my stake by the way when I I
mean when I got do you get a steak I
wasn't issued my steak uh but the reason
is Gary has several broken ones
you get it when you write about the
Confederate that's when you get the stat
okay there's a mean the story of the of
the Lost Cause has has been mobilized
around a set of political
projects goes without saying I think
it's the premise of all of this that
it's the it's the political projects
that have been pervasive over the last
150 years which find useful material in
the story of the lost cause that I I
think propels it forward and makees
Scholars relatively sometimes relatively
marginal in the conversation because
it's being driven by by by political
projects of of you know of of huge
import and significance the I'm reminded
the uh The Firm the film The Birth of a
Nation uh the
character Ben Cameron right Ben Cameron
is the the hero of the clansmen so one
of the the the the great unknown
features of American constitutional
history is that Ben Cameron uh is
modeled a guy named Rufus Bratton from
UpCountry South Carolina and Rufus
Bratton is the defendant in a case
called United States versus ay which is
the first case under the 14th Amendment
to reach the United States Supreme Court
in early 1872 it gets argued and in a in
a very very telling moment the United
States Supreme Court Ducks the question
entirely manages in the case of the man
who will be the model for The Clansman
and the birth of an and the film Birth
of a Nation to avoid saying anything
about the 14th Amendment this is unknown
because the case is United States versus
Avery because Bratton comes
alphabetically after uh Avery so it just
goes unn but but it really from from the
very beginning the political project of
telling the story of the Lost Cause has
had this political project around the
Constitutional
Amendments just one Qui the since this
theme of what's the appeal of the Lost
Cause is coming up and I I agree with
everything that's been said uh and much
of it is uh probably boils down to a
sort of uh code for for racism no no
question about
but on the other hand I mean we got some
literary Folks up here and plenty out
there you know the the sto stories of
losers have an
appeal uh stories about suffering have
an appeal now the story of black
suffering was repressed and suppressed
and kept invisible in our history for a
very long time and is only now beginning
I mean still got a long way to go till
it arrives at the central place that it
deserves but it's I I hope getting there
but if you think about the history of
literature Prometheus or King Lear or
Willie lman people like to read stories
about losers and and and the and the
South has claimed that story and so they
have and they have so that has a certain
kind of visceral appeal especially if
you don't think about it too
much T well I I think just uh picking up
on both with Gary and what Andy just
said it's also very I think important to
think about and you know you were
alluding to this uh we don't just want
to read about Los we want to read about
specific people who lost um we don't
want to read about how African-Americans
suffered uh post reconstruction and I I
want to use that um it's one thing to
think about what the incentive of the
Lost Cause is and why uh people want to
accept it I think it's also very
important to think about the
disincentive uh for accepting not simply
that the Civil War was about slavery but
as you so brilliantly just put it that
it actually wasn't about slavery it was
about the expansion of slavery um that's
a very depressing notion I think for a
nation that that uh premises itself on
freedom and liberty uh I strongly
suspect that if we accepted the academic
uh Story We the entire country um for
what the Civil War was the premacy it
had um that it would have effects uh um
Beyond uh uh those that are immediately
apparent I think people believe things
because they want to um and I think that
should never be disregarded there are
very good reasons for not believing that
a Civil War uh were about slavery would
take us into all sorts of proba policy
questions about affirmative action uh
when you really and again just this is
just it's almost I'm almost a shame to
say this but as an
African-American I had some sense that
the Civil War was about slavery I was
shocked just how much it was about
slavery I mean it was totally again as
an African-American completely
depressing David in his lectures has
that great quote and I make use of it
all the time I should start sending you
a fee or something uh fine you know you
when you begin to understand that we
talk yes we should we should um because
this really this changed my whole career
path actually but when you start to
consider that African-American slaves as
property as you so brilliantly put it
were worth all the property put together
in the country that I mean when you
start thinking about Naz Mississippi and
all the millionaires who live there more
per capita than anywhere in the country
do I have that right um state of
Mississippi the state of Miss this is
like depressing milons of people not
Millions sorry hundreds of thousands of
people were willing to die for the
expansion of slavery and the good guys
were only willing to die to not see it
expanded you know it just so happened by
luck by chance that you know we got a
emancipation who are we then what are we
then what I mean are we the land of the
freedom I think it it poses deep
existential questions that are just hard
to get to is this why the you've written
this stunning piece about why don't
blacks study the Civil War
more is this the number it that somehow
when you really do get back to the Civil
War you find that it's not such a pretty
clean moment of Jubilee it's it's not
the country well it's the country
freeing the slaves but it's not just the
country freeing the slaves it's a it's
an ugly terrible wartime process right
no I I toally and for everybody I mean
even um there are you know as an
African-American there are these moments
of Pride but it
it it is sort of I I wrote this did all
this writing about how it wasn't tragedy
but it is it really is I me there's no
way
you we argu for two hours it's not about
tragedy it's a great conversation but
you can't look at 600,000 people died
and cheer it on I mean that you know
it's bigger than that and there are
other questions there but even for
African-Americans I mean you you know
you get like the riots in uh Memphis
afterwards and you you know read about
people being raped and everything like
it's not a there's nothing good at least
in the immediate sense I mean maybe
there's a longterm good but not it will
not make you feel good immediate one
good I I was going to say that one thing
that really strikes me about the way we
write about the American Civil War when
you read a lot about other civil wars is
we don't write about the trauma of Civil
War this romantic story isn't just out
there in the popular version we as
Scholars have our own investment in the
Redemptive purposes of this war so that
we can have a kind of triumphalist at
tone about this War uh in a way that is
really difficult uh to explain to
anybody who's asking you about it and I
think one the cost of that in
scholarship as well as in popular
history is that the normal focus on the
suffering and Trauma uh that goes along
with Civil War the you the the um re
just thinking about um Contraband camps
as refugee camps for example using a
word that puts them like in other Wars
where there's displaced huge numbers of
displaced people you know okay yes the
slaves are being free but they first
have to survive the war and they're
being completely brutalized by both
armies by their masters and Mistresses I
mean that's just one part of the story
and then there's a million other human
stories of suffering and Trauma and the
other thing that really interests me
about this loss cause thing and it's so
obvious but I think probably worth
saying here is that there's two versions
of the love of the loss cause or you
know crudely put at least two
populations for this one is the ANC
people for whom it's an ancestral
history and that is still out there and
very difficult to deal with when you
encounter it in public settings but if
that was our only problem honoring my
great great grandfather exactly and
that's that's difficult but if that was
the only population for the loss cause
we wouldn't be in the trouble we're in
there's another population that uses
that that that is in California and uh
you know that is just using it as a
metaphor for conservatism and and
opposition what they regard as
opposition to you know the overreaching
of the federal government and you know
these things are different but that's
part of the reason why the the Lost
Cause continues to appeal I mean I know
it's there's and there's a romantic cast
to it which is why people who have no
familial connection to the Confederacy
somehow identify with that uh cause and
and the experience of defeat and
powerlessness that came afterwards it's
a formula that can fit a lot of causes
it's not just an ancestral attachment
yeah yeah yeah Andy yeah just one one
other comment on uh one of the
difficulties in coming to terms with the
Civil War it seems to me uh progressiv
minded people uh which is somewhat self-
serving description but one that I think
we agree uh describes most of the
academic uh profession that is people
who consider themselves liberal
left-leaning
people uh like the outcome of the Civil
War obviously the outcome of the Civil
War was the end of slavery it's a good
War we met good war in that sense
but those same people which I include
myself generally speaking uh have not
lately seen a war that we
liked that is the idea that there could
be a war who which begins as a war to
contain slavery but evolves into a war
to kill and end slavery uh is it's it
scrambles the mind because we we talk
about the fog of War and the mission
shift in war and once you unleash the
gods of War only bad things happen is
our general view of modern history this
is good Mission creep when is that it's
good Mission creep exactly a great
phrase so what do we what do we do with
that I mean i' I've asked some of my my
colleagues who were certainly a few
outliers who were in favor of the Iraq
War because they thought there really
were weapons of mass destruction there
but most people were in our world were
against it and yet retrospectively we're
for the Civil War oh yeah so that's a
that's a confusion I think that we
haven't quite resolved I David I can't
help saying that I don't even think most
of the men who volunteered and put on
blue uniforms would have said the war
was about the extension of slavery they
would have said it was about
preservation of the union and that meant
something to them that we have lost to
them had had a very specific meeting
meaning they saw slaveholders as
oligarchs they didn't see them as part
of the tradition from the founding
generation they believed that small D
democracy was at stake because they
didn't believe it existed in the South
because of the oligarchic rule there
they believed that there was both a
larger project in place in North America
that is saving the handiwork of the
founders and chastising these oligarchs
but they also looked across the ocean
and said this their democracy hasn't
worked anywhere the Revolutions of the
late 1840s failed everywhere democracy
is in Retreat if it's going to be saved
anywhere it has to be here and if these
oligarchs can destroy the nation just
because the presidential candidate they
favored wasn't elected in an election
that no one said was crooked they just
didn't like the result then the
oligarchs and The Aristocrats and the
monarchist are going to be able to say
we told you people aren't capable to he
said it we all think Lincoln said it and
then everybody said oh that must be the
case but in fact even the barely
literate soldiers said almost precisely
the same thing Lincoln in his usual way
captures brilliantly what is is really
very widely held among the white loyal
citizen ring so I'm I can't even give
them credit for going to war most of
them to limit the expans the Democrats
sure is held didn't I mean 45% of the
north are
Democrats they are not in board on board
with anything relating to I have to ask
that other Democratic party in that
other century when when does it become
though like a semantic question because
if the thing that's threatening Union is
the extension of slavery you may be for
Union but the thing you're actually
fighting against Union is the expansion
of slavy so the Democrats wouldn't have
said the thing threatening the union is
the expansion of slavery the thing
threatening the union is that an
oligarchic class in the South has
decided to dismember the union just
because they didn't get the president
isn't that why they dismember the Union
Yes but those are two different things
why you fight to save the Union why you
decide to secede they're related of
course but they're different questions
they're different questions you know I
really go ahead John well there's a
there's a mean alongside all this
there's a a military history dimension I
think to the Lost Cause And this is a
you know an application of the loser
stories are are uh popular stories uh
but I think uh I I believe I'm right
when I said there's an underpopulation
of Union side reenactors uh and and this
is not a this is not a coincidence
because in the era well no I think I
think so I think it's not strange I
think that um in the the era of modern
industrialized Warfare doesn't provide
opportunities for heroism that is
heroism on the battlefield is
unavailable uh after the the rise of
certain forms of weaponry and so picket
charge it would be really pointless to
be a union side reenactor and picket
charge right this is but to be a
Confederate side reenactor is to try to
to try to uh uh see through the Triumph
of heroism in the face of mass
industrial Slaughter and there's a
there's an appeal to that story uh which
I think is an
important this a military history side
of this what about black reenactors what
do you guys know about that I've been
meeting a lot of black reenactors out on
the on the circuit and those guys are
interesting they well my my favorite
experience with black rean
actors was in 1997 the 200th excuse me
100th
anniversary of uh the unveiling of the
Sha mamor the great Augustus St Gardens
monument in Boston to the 54th
Massachusetts um Boston held a
extraordinary conference around that
anniversary scholarly conference for
about two and a half days a whole bunch
of us giv papers on this and that and
this and that but the people who stole
the show were about 100 black reenactors
who took over this event in a way they
had a whole panel of five black
reenactors of different ages discussing
what they do and why they do well it
turned out almost all of them started
right after the movie Glory they found
each other after the movie Glory Glory
is a wed glory is a watershed in there
popular memory and you've written about
this but then they started forming units
and regiments and so on and so forth and
during the
ceremony in front of the show Memorial
which many of you may know I hope um not
only did these 100 black reenactors
reenact the March the 54th in front of
the monument did formations it was
really quite moving but one of them
stood in front of the monument on the
pavement beneath the stage during the
whole ceremony and kept doing a kind of
about face for an hour and a half as
though he was on the
monument it was a kind of Street Theater
unlike any anything else I've ever seen
and he got you standing ovation he got a
greater Ovation than Colin Powell got
for the keynote address and it was a
pretty good talk by Colin Pow by the way
um I This is complicated I've done
events in the South charlon South
Charleston South
Carolina where we uh dedicated a
monument to the first Memorial Day and a
group of black reenactors were there
these guys are serious and they I no
longer crack jokes about reenactors
partly because of this experience but it
also says something about my own
attitudes doesn't it black reenactors
are the good
War all those Confederate
reenactors but if you really talk to a
lot of them they're they're different
kinds of them some of them are out to
drink beer on a weekend some of them are
out to just find an an authenticity rush
and some of them are out to just uh uh
find the past because they don't like
living in the present um there a lot of
reasons people do this but uh black
reenacting is I mean I think I think we
can rise do you think well I mean I
think we reached a moment in the 9s when
doing this was available to
African-Americans in ways it hadn't been
before but and people discovered black
soldiers because of Glory I was in
Gettysburg uh on November 19th last year
there's a lecture Civil War lecture
that's given on the the anniversary of
Lincoln's gettysburger addess and they
have and reenactors March in Gettysburg
thousands of them and there were a lot
of black reenactors and they got the
biggest response by far from the crowd
is when they went by they're cool uh
they've become really cool I mean in in
in reenacting circles I really wanted to
get John talking about um I may let
somebody ask you this about Liberty and
the common good and actually some quotes
from yesterday's Supreme Court in terms
of Legacy but I want to lob one more
question here into tanasi
first uh this came up in my
undergraduate semin Minar two days ago
at Great length what do you think the
internet is doing will continue to do
the the sheer ubiquity and democracy of
the internet to to to not only this
aspect of historical memory but
historical consciousness historical
memory generally and you and you're H it
as much as anybody right I don't want to
get in trouble here I saw excerpts from
this piece Gary wrote about our bloggers
I wasn't going to say that he wrote
all right I would love to see it I would
love to see it um what what there two uh
there two aspects
um the first is uh it really has uh
created uh a disperate a wide I
shouldn't say disperate a widespread
audience for the kind of lost caus ISM
that we've heard uh denounced up here
that's the bad thing um so um the whole
black there you go there you it's all
it's all over and I think it's gotten a
kind of legitimacy on the internet that
it might not have otherwise I think the
internet is a huge part part of that
um I I'll talk about it from my
experience um and and and that is this
uh I was always uh someone who you know
considered himself somewhat of a history
buff even though I dropped out of
college I had you know kept history as
as a primary interest of mine it was
what most of my reading was about and I
I took a break uh around 2008 after my
first book came out and I was greatly
looking forward to this moment where I
would be able to begin reading again as
a fan and not as someone who was writing
a book I was so happy about that um God
I can't even remember doing yeah no it's
just a f I didn't no one told me you
were going to lose that um that it would
all be about your work um I went back
read a biography about ID to be wells in
the background it was this thing the
Civil War um and reconstruction so I
said okay I'll go read a book about Rec
I read another book about
reconstruction uh Civil War started to
loom a little bit larger at that point I
was blogging and one of the things I do
on the blog is I always talk about what
I'm reading and so you know they would
be these kind of faint references to the
Civil War and one day someone said you
know you should really check out this
was a commenter just an anonymous
commenter you should really check out
James mcfist's um B battlecry Freedom um
and I I can't even Des I can't even give
words to what happened after that but in
short you know I'm here now largely
because of the internet and it's it's
it's a weird thing because um I for for
most of my career I was a print
journalist but the internet offers a
kind of uh obviously
interactivity uh if it's a properly
curated conversation the crowd is much
smarter than you uh than you really
think it is if you clear it away um
people can tell you what you're wrong
about what you're right about and
they'll be intelligent I mean I I think
I've gotten some of your I came to uh uh
uh to uh most of your work through the
internet some guy emailed me one day he
said hey this guy David blight there's
this lecture series up you should go
watch it was on the internet and I went
and watch it and it just it absolutely
blew me away um this was recommended to
me by the crowd um we have a very very
different relationship I don't have to
presume to be right they can be right
they can be directing me I can be taking
a seminar from them um so I think the
sort of um democracy of it for me is
just extremely extremely extremely uh
exciting uh it's not the usual position
that a writer uh finds himself you don't
usually get the opportunity to go
somewhere and say hey I don't know
anything about this why don't you tell
me um but you can do that on the
internet and it's okay there's no you
know sort of presumption of authority
that's just been intensely uh liberating
for me it it um it's been path altering
in a way that I just never
expected any other points of view on the
Internet or you want to you want to pass
well what do you supp can I just say I
hope all of you guys uh blog I I really
I really really do because I just I'm
sorry I just want to add this really
quick one of the big big problems and
one of my great frustrations is uh the
wall like J store like I fortunately I
have some access to J store and that
really really helps but most people do
not and there's so many EXC we get you a
library card yes really but there's so
many exciting things that you guys are
doing and it's not even a lot of it
isn't even that hard to read but getting
it out to because because that's the rap
on historians right I mean the rap is
always so hard to read so but it's
actually not true it's actually that
hard it's true sometimes yes yes yes yes
but I really but getting you know
historians to the public I mean that
that's really been you know something
that I've really really been on so I
hope you guys take up the cause yourself
s if the firewall comes down we'll have
a test of that and we can't afford that
test I think that's the that's right I
was just going to say I mean I know it's
um the sort of very very predictable uh
um whining but I'm curious about your
perspective on this and those of you who
spend more time blogging and things when
you do for like the New York Times
website I did one on the Confederate
Constitution for example which I really
love doing they blew the production
values you couldn't even read the thing
was they they took a they had this cool
idea that uh they should have a
manuscript copy of the Confederate
Constitution and there's this fiction
that it's a copy of the US Constitution
which it is not and so I wrote the an
introduction and then these little
hyperlinks explaining what the
difference was in each place where they
significantly changed the Constitution
so you can scroll over the document and
these links pop up and I you know I get
to explain what words they changed and
what difference it made and that was a
really really cool thing to do um but
the conversation that went on after it
was one of the most polarized
conversations I've ever seen in my life
and it wasn't encouraging it was really
kind of disturbing and it didn't seem to
make anybody think anything except they
were right to start with that all the
academics are left-wing morons and uh
you know the and elitists and the
Confederacy um there's you know really
was a fine this was a fine Constitution
for a fine country that we're making it
up about slavery even though you're
going through the thing you know the
word slavery appears in the Confederate
Constitution does not appear in the US
Constitution they write a clause saying
that their own Congress can never uh
ever write a law limiting the right of
property in slaves which comes to bite
them when they want to enlist men in the
army they can't free them they've tied
their own hands which is why they have
to go beg to the states they do not have
a clause that says that that the states
have a right of secession these are
interesting things um but the
conversation that that ensued was really
really vitriolic and polarized there was
no middle ground there at all it's free
I got I just got called the other day
for a piece I did slate.com just another
Yale geriatric
Professor so you know I take issue with
the problem though is this is actually
this is not it's not either you you
guys' fault the problem is we've taken
the notion of democracy a little too far
and it has not you know gotten into
people's heads on the internet yet that
you really should curate your comments
that you really should have a goal
something your go it's not just an open
space for people to spout off I keep
telling them that yeah I mean I always
try to explain I said look if uh I I I
have a Blog I'm hosting a space I would
not let you come into my house and
insult one of my guests I would ask you
to leave that's what would happen in
normal space so if you want the space to
be elevated you have to treat it that
way that that's our fault we haven't
quite gotten it through our heads that
we should commit resources for it being
that way I'm sorry that happen so
interesting it happens 99% of the time
it does Happ there are 100 other
legacies we could take up here but let's
take a few questions if you have a
question the there are two mics uh you
can stand at the mic or Tom thirston or
Melissa McGrath question
probably
question I really
right into the mic sir if you would oh
Tom turn it on if you
would here we go I really wonder how you
feel with the diminution of interest in
public schools in particular downgrading
history history is not
taught except for 45 minutes one day in
a month
after lunch or something I have 12
grandchildren they don't know their
history and they're not expected to
because it's been woven into a thing
called social
studies and that's it so the crown of
people to replace you are coming from
the highest academic quadrant and they
haven't had this learning experience
going back our students here well your
students are different but even even the
idea of the Black History Month that
doesn't tie to the Civil War in any way
hardly because they don't want to upset
the Little Darlings about that kind of
thinking and I really think that there
is something that ought to be coming out
of higher academics to tell the school
administrators superintendents Mayors or
whoever makes these decisions yeah that
history is important well we we try uh
well we're not in charge of school
administrators I'm I'm well aware I'm
well aware but I've heard an aw well sir
this is a good news bad news story I've
heard an awful lot of people say on the
panel today
about how many books they've written and
how many things they've written no I
said how many books they've written
that's all my book said I'm sorry if I
disrupted you no no you didn't disrupt
anything no this is a good news bad news
story look uh the good news
is Andy Gary all Steph we
all every summer we teach teacher
institutes all over the this country
hundreds of them we reach thousands of
teachers now this never happened until
about 15 years ago in fact the guild
andman Institute is responsible for much
of it on the other hand uh the impact
we're having is always a hard thing to
measure uh it's a hard thing to measure
and often we hear from those teachers
the very complaint you just made I I
should say one thing to confirm my
reputation as a Jeremiah who sees things
going downhill uh unfortunately I think
the gentleman is more than right and and
I would add to that that uh the
percentage of students majoring now
statistics can be a little misleading
but the percentage of students majoring
in some humanistic discipline which to
my mind certainly includes history at
our Elite universities including this
one is rapidly declining that's
absolutely right so uh we should be
worried one of the best ways to get our
world and the and the world of secondary
school and middle school teachers
together together was the teaching
American history grant program fabulous
which was defunded it's about to die
next year about to die it's almost over
with it was not very much money but it's
it's Congress is not going to renew that
no it's
not um next question man in the Yale
shirt who's now a high school teacher in
Texas yep yeah know I I I'm I teach 10
grade world history to35 high school
students God bless you I know I don't
know how what are you doing here um you
should
escaping escaping escaping is a polite
way of saying it um so sort of like a
two part sort of first you know um you
know sort of picking you know working
back on that past question you know sort
of like a lot of the struggle I've had
sort of and you know I've talked to the
US history in sorry in our US History
Department sort of trying to work
through you know what's you know how do
we teach the Civil War what's sort of
the narrative what's sort of the
interest um it's sort of a struggle
sometimes it's a lot of struggle you're
trar to be like you know it's an event
that happened there was was fighting
uhhuh and there there were they were
slaves and they were afraid and that's
that's the narrative and it's a very
it's sort of my my my first question
sort of like how does one you know so
your first problem that you've observed
is just the sheer superficiality the
sheer superficiality of them that just
completely turns them off and so it's
sort of you know hard to sort think
about no how does one sort of try to
invest you know what are some sort of
any experiences you guys had where
you've had to like sort of invest
someone sort of caring about the event
itself um and the second thing is you
know I'm sort of I I I you know the Lost
Cause narrative is are very interesting
to me because know I I think of the
fauler quote and you know you know and
it's interesting because which is the
you know the you know you're looking at
picket charge I always mess it up but
you know pick charge you have a boy to
you know
boy it's sort of it's rather pervasive
because I I've always said you know I
was a you know 13-year-old you know you
know Hispanic male um who who very
strongly identified with the Lost cost
you did in South Texas of all places
which is bizarre and sort of pointing
out to the pervasiveness of this whole
thing why is that bizarre that's where
you grew up and that's what you were
taught right in in 99% Mexican
environment which we don't talk about
the Civil War at all oh that that's the
bizarre part started the pointing out to
the pervasiveness of the whole lost
cosmetology who's got the next question
on this side of the room
yes ma' you um uh this is for TNC I'm a
really big fan of your blog um I
consider myself a member of The Horde
and um one of um one of my my favorite
pieces of yours is um the piece that you
wrote about Ron Paul leis faran um and
you know you obviously you know what you
wrote but I guess for people who haven't
read it you know um you you basically
saying that you know sort of like young
white people have like gravitated to Ron
Paul because like they're disaffected
with the two party system
in the way that like young black men
gravitated to like leis farakhan and I
was wondering since you know you follow
current political Trends is there um you
know someone uh you know someone maybe
like n gingr or somebody in the current
political sphere who embodies the Lost
Cause for a lot of like disaffected
white people basically well it was Ron
Paul for a while I mean it it's
fascinating there actual video I've
never seen this before maybe it's I'm
sure it has happened before but this
video of Paul in
2004 lambasting Lincoln with a
Confederate flag right behind him and he
wants to run I you think about this
literally a flag of treason but running
for president of the United States lamb
basting I couldn't even I mean my eyes
just like went like this I couldn't even
even knowing who Ron Paul is um so I
think it it pretty much was him I mean
literally actually him uh he uh went on
Tim R said this must have been though I
guess uh 08 it would have been uh he
went on Meet the Press and made the
argument about Lincoln being a tyrant
slavery would have ended anyway um I
don't know anybody with the national
States like that who's has aggressively
made that argument and is Ron Paul even
a southerner I mean this again is the
interest he is a southern but is he from
Texas he is from Texas okay all right
he's originally from Texas okay okay all
right actually so he is a southerner all
right well there you go you got it um
but his appeal is certainly much broader
than that you know it really really is
um so I I would say I would say him if
George Allen wins uh the senate race uh
George Allen's another person who's very
much you know identified that's in
Virginia in Virginia and I think he
isn't a Texan though I mean he isn't a
southerner I think he's actually from
somewhere I want to say he grew up in
California or something like
that yes well his dad was dad was
coaching was a football coach moving
around right right right um so I mean
yeah yes it's still but I think even
saying that I I would be shocked if
somebody does that again if they
literally stand up in front of of a
Confederate flag it was not the issue
that it had been in a republican Prime
writers sh which is
interesting thank you next question
we'll take one
more Pier thank you um I actually have a
small question uh referring to I think
what Professor mccu mentioned a little
earlier about how um it's kind of
exceptional in America that a little Lou
up here oh um I actually have a question
about how I think it was uh what
Professor McCurry mentioned a bit
earlier of how it seems that America
sort of uh exceptionally interested in
it in its Civil War and I'm just
wondering but has as as a historian did
you ever get the impression that at
least in recent years interest in the
American Civil War has sort of been
increasing in foreign countries I mean
Professor blight mentioned uh the kind
of a conference in Jerusalem I think it
was and you know just in my own
experience I've had a few friends from
you know on the internet on Facebook and
stuff from you know countries like
Europe my relatives living in London and
uh just uh even I think a couple of
people from Asia asking me questions
about the Civil War the American Civil
War and just sort of you know wanting to
talk about it with me so I'm just
wondering if you've gotten the
impression that this this uh this
American Civil War has come to become
has sort of been uh growing more
interesting to historians or just the
general public in foreign countries in
Europe Asia or
wherever you know I really don't know
it's a fascinating uh question the
person who invited us was actually
actually uh an Israeli who was trained
by mcferson at Princeton who uh came to
the United States with her father on a
fellowship when she was a little kid he
was a historian of early modern Europe I
think and um she saw something on TV
when she was in sixth grade in Princeton
New Jersey and got hooked on the Civil
War and went back to Israel and came
back here as a graduate student and
wrote a dissertation on um how much
people basically on the disruption and
mobility of human beings during the
Civil War um and then when we went to
Israel we met all these people who wrote
on the Civil War including the American
Civil War as a case study of various
things like Innovations in communication
and networks and technology and things
like that so um but you know we're a
little insulated we I I don't think that
I don't have any sense that there's some
upward Trend in uh International
interest in the subject what do you
think David well there what I think we
can say Pierre is there's no lack of
Interest
uh in this American problem of race and
our pluralism and our history with this
dilemma I mean that's what's always
fascinated the rest of the world about
us I taught 20 years ago 20 years ago I
taught for a year in Germany it was
right after the Ken Burns film series
came out and I taught the Ken burs film
series all nine parts of it with a
German class in Munich at the very same
time mun uh German National Television
was running at German TV dubbed into
German so it was an interesting sort of
laboratory and it was fascinating they
they were fascinated with the film
series but I got very different
questions than I would get from
Americans one I remember vividly was the
German student who came up to me after
watching an episode one day I also gave
some lectures I didn't just show movies
but he came up after me he said why why
do you Americans always think that
everything that happens to you is the
biggest thing that's ever happened he
said said have you ever heard of the 30
years War yeah and I said no most
Americans have not heard the 30 Years
War we don't know about that but we were
getting a lot of that last summer yeah
yeah Andy go ahe just quickly I I can't
give you an empirical answer to you I
can never give empirical answers to any
questions but uh we want to remember I
think that there are a lot of countries
in the world including what we call the
developed Western World and and other
parts of the world where they haven't
settled these questions of federalism
right I mean Scotland wants maybe out of
the United Kingdom Belgium is going to
split up any day probably not with
Bloodshed but they're debating uh these
questions so uh I think that's one
reason that interest in in how we
settled our uh problem in this regard is
rising and I just wanted to say one of
thing U about what teni said about Ron
Paul when I gave a talk in Washington
must be close to 20 years ago now sort
of hegra talk about Lincoln which is my
mode with Lincoln uh somebody came up to
me afterwards it was shortly after the
break up of the so Soviet Union or begin
the Soviet Union was beginning to break
up and this person came up to me and
said Lincoln was a
monster he was a tyrant here we are uh
you know we we're we don't want to see
the the Moscow impose its will on all
these states that are breaking away how
dare he take the action he took at the
cost of so many hundreds of thousands of
lives and and I had some mumbling
answers to it uh you know that the out
come was good for everybody um but you
know that point of view is is still
alive there there are the equivalent of
Civil War Buffs in there are a lot of
them in England there are civil war
roundtables in England I've spoken to
the one in London they're reenactors too
they're reenactors in Germany and in
England in Australia and other places
and there's a long tradition among
British writers to write about the
American Civil War very prominent
including Winston Churchill uh so
there's always been an interest there a
serious interest in some sort of
classing texts has come from British
authors late 19th century down through
the mid 20th there's at least one place
where I think there's a boom in interest
abroad in the Civil War which is to say
in the um in the world of international
human rights and humanitarian law noos
uh we now live in a world in which for
international law purposes our armed
conflicts are non- international armed
conflicts this has an acronym you call
them niaks if you know if you on the
inside I'm not on the inside uh and and
for that population which is to say the
kinds of armed conflicts that that that
are going on all around the world the
United States Civil War has become the
quintessential reference point both
because it produces an international a
body of international law and it
produces a body of international law
that's specifically for the kinds of
conflicts not conflicts between states
so there's a huge boom in among military
lawyers NOS it's really it's a
specialized kind of interest but it's uh
it's really important it's interesting
that reminds me the way you guys are
talking about this reminds me that one
of the subjects that does have
international interest um is secession
there's a lot of interest in because
because secession is handled so
differently now through International
negotiation and there all these
protocols that have grown up I mean you
would know a lot more about this but
it's really striking to teach secession
now and you have available to you all
this stuff about subsequent secessions
and also you know the success rate of
secessions which are not is not very
high which sort of puts the Confederacy
you know even if you like them they're
not um but there but there's a big
tendency towards negotiated solutions
that permit secessions under certain
conditions so political scientists
international law people are very
interested in this and of course the the
looming case is is the US well in
reconstruction is we need to end here
soon but has always had a deep residents
abroad because how many other places in
the world have had to reconstruct after
War there have been multip mle
comparative conferences about
reconstruction uh about
occupation um I was once invited one in
Germany to a whole big conference about
the history of occupations and I was
told we'd like you to speak about the
American occupation of the South during
reconstruction right now I had not been
raised on that argument that it was an
occupation so here I was talking about
it as an occupation just a couple
quickies quick thoughts
um I actually wanted to get John on this
a bit more but
if if you want to look for a civil war
Legacy and I know many of you know this
but all you really need to do which most
of us don't do is look at the hundreds
and hundreds of bills before state
legislator in this country uh all over
the country uh particularly in
legislatures ruled by Republican
majorities but that just happens to be
the political affiliation of our time
and all of those bills are about State's
rights they're about bringing power back
from Federal authority to the state
sometimes it's about endangered species
sometimes it's about um uh land rights
it's often about the Commerce Clause
it's often about the health health care
law Montana has a bill right now I don't
know if it's passed yet which would
require the FBI the Federal Bureau of
Investigation to get the approval of a
local sheriff to ever make an arrest in
a county and so on and so on and so on
hundreds and hundreds of these bills
it's just a flood of them now the only
way one can begin to understand a
context for these is to go back to this
particular historical moment uh we have
a rough history with states rights but
we seem to have a political culture now
that is almost utterly unaware of it
which goes back to the point of what we
actually know about our history and I
frankly think that every time someone
Milds the word big government whether
they're for it or against it they're
talking about the big government that
the Lincoln Administration
created that's when big government began
in this country and uh everybody talks
about big government but no one ever
talks about where it came from or who
created it um anyway I just thought I'd
point that out uh it's been
extraordinary pan we could go on all
night but we too want to go have dinner
um we're going to walk out here though
where there a table with the books of
all these folks if you want to buy
anybody's book go right through that
door that's where we'll be um would you
please join me in thanking this
extraordinary
[Applause]
[Music]
panel
[Applause]
stere